- [Narrator] Are you facing
a challenging dilemma
in your life right now?
The Dilemma is a new Jubilee show,
and we're looking for people
who are seeking advice,
willing to be vulnerable,
and anonymously sharing
their dilemmas on camera.
Click on the link in
the description below,
and share your dilemma.
- What are we ranking
off of right now, looks?
- I feel like I'm like one or two, no cap.
- Really?
- Yeah. I'm black like, for real.
- [Narrator] If you had to
rank yourself against others,
based on a specific trait,
what would it say about how you see them,
and how they see you? To find out,
we brought together seven people,
and had them rank each other
based on perceived blackness.
Then we had them complete a DNA test,
so we could compare the results.
This is Ranking.
- [Interviewer] What makes someone Black?
- Being black is just
you identifying yourself
as a black person, and realizing
that you do have plights,
and experiences that can sometimes
make life harder for you.
- I think someone who is
darker in general is gonna have
a different experience in
someone who's light skinned,
and that's gonna constitute
how they walk through the world
and their blackness. Doesn't
affect how you see yourself,
but it does reflect how
other people see you.
- Yeah, I agree.
- I know for a fact there are experiences
that I'm never going to
experience because I am lighter.
That's something that I've
acknowledged my whole life,
but also having a mother
who is much darker,
you know we go out in public
and I see how they treat her.
And I feel, you know, the same rage,
but I know that I'll never
experience it myself.
- Especially, well, for me
being down in Orange County,
where it's predominantly white people,
when it comes to white
people, it's more like,
okay, you're one of us,
but there's a little inklings
of darker skin people
who will look at me and kind of tell like,
okay you're not just white,
you're mixed with something.
- Yeah.
- My mom's side, they
always make fun of me.
Oh, you sound like a white person.
I don't use African American vernacular,
Not that, that is what
makes a black person.
You can be very well spoken.
- I feel like I just like switch it up.
Like if I'm around,
you know, black people,
I'm like you know "What's going on?"
And around white people I'm
like "Oh hey, how are you?"
Like I speak differently
for sure, a hundred percent
- [Group] Code switching!
- So code switching is me!
- I definitely feel that though,
'cause like, it's kind of second nature.
'Cause you go home, you're
like you have your people,
and then you go to school.
It's like, you kind of
have to like switch it
up just in order to be,
even be like accepted,
and even like get certain
treatment from your teachers.
- Yeah. Like I didn't really
feel like I fit in anywhere
because I was cool with the white kids.
I was cool with the black kids.
I was cool with every like nationality.
But I felt like in order for
people to take me serious
I had to put on like professional maybe,
- Customer service voice.
- People would look at vernacular,
like you said, and look at it
as unprofessional, you know?
- Yeah.
- Being around some white crowds,
I definitely feel like I had to,
you know reserve parts of myself,
just because I felt
like I was being judged.
Like they could clearly tell
you're not like just white,
and I think that's why I've
stayed so far away from being
around white people and
why I do kind of have,
you know that kind of like,
"I don't really know you like that."
Like, you know, just 'cause I
don't like feeling like that.
I fully expect to be
at the end of the line.
- Me too.
- Me as well.
- I definitely came into it,
looking at the physical features first.
- I'm gonna make my way down here.
- Gonna switch with you
- Actually come on.
- I might switch off too though.
- Y'all think I'm number one?
- No no, y'all two.
- Yeah.
- God damn it.
- Like the the three of us,
we have one white parent,
one black parent, right?
- Both of my parents are black.
- Both your parents are black, okay.
- They just happened to be,
the two light brights that
got together, You know?
- So I did think of him
like, oh he's biracial.
Then he said he had two black
parents and I was like, "Huh."
- She and I, I kinda
wanna switch between us.
- Okay, but hear me out.
I feel like hair is also a
big part in that, you know?
And my hair is very white,
like I have white texture hair.
Like the thin straight, like
there's no nothing to my hair.
- I see what you mean.
'Cause usually if I straighten my hair,
the texture just does change a little,
and then I appear to be more Caucasian.
- [Johnathon] What are we
ranking it off of right now?
Looks? Are we going off looks?
- Is it based on looks?
- I guess so!
- I just wanted to be in the middle.
- Cause looks I would put myself one more.
- I feel like I'm like one or two, no cap.
- Really?
- Yeah, I'm black bro for
real. Like I'm black for real.
It don't look like it, but
I swear to God I'm black.
I mean as far back as I can go bro, black.
- Yes bro same, same.
- Like the reason why I feel
like I'm here is because,
my mom and dad are both Eritrea,
And so like I know
where we stem back from.
So I feel like that's why
I feel like I can be here.
- Valid.
- I think that's very valid, yeah.
- That's super valid actually.
- I was more sure about my,
DNA than the rest of them I think.
- I feel like I'm right here on the low,
I think I'm where you should be.
- Why? Tell me why.
- Because bro, like, I don't
know. I have a feeling.
- Yeah, the feeling?
- Okay. I disagree with that feeling.
It's based off, like literally
just based off skin tone.
- That's the only,
- What do you mean?
- Cause' I don't know what else
I'd rank it off of, right now.
- I feel like eye color. You look like
- Okay yeah, I have light eyes.
- You have light eyes.
- I have very light eyes.
- My eyes are black as the night sky.
- I have no explanation
of that, other than
- That's what I'm saying, come on.
There gotta me some drop in there bro.
- It's so deep in there
though, they can't trace it.
- What do you have that he doesn't have?
- I got the same hair texture
as you, some braids but.
Eyes dark as hell.
I was lowkey, slightly
gaslighting to try to be second.
So I was talking about his colored eyes.
- I'll let you take it,
I'll let you take it.
- Yeah bro, bro.
- I'd go one, two, three, four.
- 'Aight
- I'd put you four.
- Trust, 'aight. Okay.
- Why'd you put yourself in the middle?
- So you could get a good
angle of me, you feel me?
- That's a good question
- I would honestly put you two.
- Yeah I was going to ask,
why are you in the middle?
(all talking at once)
- I wanted to get shine on myself.
- They're trying to put you in the middle,
that's what it is.
- They're trying to put my
in the middle, that's true.
- I don't think she's in the middle,
I don't think she's in
the middle for sure.
- He in the middle.
- I think you in the middle
bro, I'm not gonna lie.
- Okay.
- Let's switch.
- You getting six would be crazy
- Bro. No, don't do me like that bro.
I have a call, ask some questions.
Somebody cheated, somebody not bro.
- I don't know.
- The confidence.
- It's the confidence as well.
- She knew where she at.
- Yeah, I agree. The
confidence is very convincing.
- [Narrator] We're ranking on blackness.
- Yeah.
- [Narrator] Not confidence.
- But like, I've definitely
encountered a lot of,
black people who are 100%
black with very fair skin.
So it's like, it's not like
it's impossible. You know?
- People say like, oh no, we're
not basing off skin color,
that's outdated. But, you
saw what they was like.
Bro, they were trying
to put me in the middle.
- I think we should do
some cultural like, stuff.
- Yeah.
- Some experiences.
- Okay.
- If that's the case, then
I'm not here, I can't be here.
- Wait, experiences?
(talking over each other)
- But that's a part of blackness.
- I don't mean like,
genetically blackness.
- Yeah, it still does.
- Your experience?
- Yeah, a hundred percent.
- How? 'Cause could have been
raised in some random city,
every single white person ever
and be completely different.
- It's this environment.
- Like I don't think it matters,
Cause I mean we spit in a little thing.
Like, that has nothing
to do with experience.
But I'm so serious, I'm so serious.
- You're right, you're right though.
- I see what you're saying,
I see what you're saying.
- Yeah. But then the dilemma is like,
we don't know each other's
genes, we only know ours.
- Yeah.
- So we have to base it off of something,
that we can all agree on.
- Yeah.
- Experience shapes our blackness,
how it's seen by the rest of the world.
Regardless, like your
DNA can say one thing,
but how you experience
and go through the world,
is gonna be completely different.
- I like that. We can go by that, then.
- It's just, it's a fact of reality.
- I have a question to
define y'all blackness,
do y'all keep plastic bags?
- Yeah.
- When your mom called you to take
the chicken out the
freezer, when'd you do it?
- Never. Never.
- She get home mad.
- Learning that no matter
how much black we had in us,
we had common experiences,
community and things like that,
I think that was really cool.
- What's some black stuff?
- How y'all eat your spaghetti?
You put brown sugar in it? Come on now.
- Excuse me?
- Brown sugar in your spaghetti?
- I don't know about that.
- What?
- Oh my gosh, bro.
- Hey take her to the-
- No, try it!
Bro, That might just be a you thing.
No it's not bro, that's a black thing bro.
Brown sugar in spaghetti, trust me bro.
- Yeah, no. (laughs)
- I've personally never heard of that.
- Maybe white sugar?
- Nah, I'd rather eat dirt.
- I don't know if that's
like a common black thing.
- It's like...
- My mistake.
What? I feel like we locked it in.
- Okay.
- That brown, no. I almost
had the plight where I'm like
you know what she probably
the second blackest,
but that she said brown
sugar. I'm like yo.
- That's a black thing, bro. Deada**.
- Brown sugar aside, I think
she should stay lowkey.
- Yeah, I would leave it.
I ain't never heard about
brown sugar neither.
- I'm kind of torn, I
might switch them two,
and then we'd be cool. Just for that.
- I'm not mad at it.
- I mean, I guess. I
would still switch us.
I would, I would.
- Yo, oh my.
- Wayne, do you know anything about your
background and stuff?
- Both my great grandparents
is Caucasian, Yeah.
- Wait, what?
- Interesting.
- Okay, wait a second.
- And to me that would say-
- My great grandparents are black. No way.
- I have a great grandmother
who's alive and black,
like she's a black woman.
- Oh no, no, no. Like her
name's Karen, for real.
- They were talking about the brown sugar,
kinda put me in the middle,
and the homeboy great
grandparents not even full black,
like.
No, we gotta change this now.
- Something has to change I think, lowkey.
- My great grandparents
are both black, both sides.
- I think y'all should switch.
- Yeah.
- Josselyn go ahead, yeah.
- Now look at y'all,
basing it on my skin color.
- No.
- Y'all need to switch too.
- What about your grandparents?
- That's crazy.
- Based on my skin color,
I'm sure they didn't have any indication
that I might have white in my DNA.
- I think this is the closest we've come.
- [Group] Yeah.
- Yeah, I think so.
- [Narrator] Who are the two people who's
results did not come in again?
Okay perfect, of course.
- Wow.
- [Narrator] I'm gonna call out the order,
of the people I do
have. So Jonathan, 89.6.
- That's high.
- Yeah, 'cause I have black
- Yeah, so colored eyes
do not matter at all.
'Cause, that boy black.
- [Narrator] And then Wayne, 67%.
- Wow.
- [Narrator] And then Steve, 56.5%
Bryanna, 39.3%.
- [Narrator] And then Ciarra, 20.2%.
- It's giving very, "I'm rocking with Mark
'cause Mark rocking with us." You know?
- You are freaking African
Americans, plus Mark.
You know what I'm saying?
Which I'm rocking with Mark,
'cause Mark is rocking with us.
- Not Mark rocking with us bro.
- [Narrator] Between these two,
how do you think they will land?
- 100.
- 95.
- I'mma say 98 actually. Just in case.
- You said 89, and then 67 right?
- That's a huge jump.
- You could fall in between
the twenty something percent.
- I feel like we got
everything else right.
I feel like we did it, on God.
- I guess I kind of disagreed,
with what our final ranking was.
I wanted to switch with Josselyn because,
I just felt it.
- The person that stood
out to me the most,
was probably Josselyn.
- Josselyn
- [Narrator] I'm gonna start
with Serena, who's not here.
But she is in the correct
spot. She's at 99.8
- Oh wow.
- Yo, she's OG. She
true blood right there.
- Then Josselyn is coming in at 75.8%.
- Oh we were so close.
- That puts her right after Wayne,
that means Jonathan
you're actually second.
- So I don't, listen,
Jonathan has me messed up.
- I thought it was interesting,
like 'cause she was
very confident about it.
- Yeah I just think her confidence,
and the fact of who she
is, is really admirable.
- There's no one right way to be black,
and just because she might not have had
the same experiences
as other black people,
or have more melanin
than other black people.
Like I don't think that
invalidates her blackness at all.
I know. I don't know y'all like that,
but a few days after we shot,
I found out I was pregnant. So.
- Congratulations.
- [Narrator] Congratulations,
congratulations.